here's johnson
ready to start this ball game tonight at
petco park in san diego for the
right-hander pierce johnson you're gonna
get one of two the curve ball or the
fastball his first major league start
for the right-hander 30 year old and
that's strike three
gets him to go around and pierce johnson
strikes out trey turner to start the
night
and the series that's got machado in
right field
muncie grounded into the ship but it is
kim on the right side who makes the
throw two outs in the first inning 2-2
pitch to justin turner
elevates and strikes him out good first
for pierce johnson julio
you go back to late june really since he
last faced the padres when they tagged
him for six runs in four innings he has
the number three era in baseball behind
just bueller and the brewers corbin
burns
they raise them up with that fastball
perfectly located for the first time
that brings up fernando tattis jr
breaking ball grounded to
trade turner when the shift makes the
play here's machado
first pitch breaking ball pulled on a
bounce to seeger
and back to back pitches get back to
back out bill smith leads off this
inning for the dodgers smith has been
much better against fastballs than he
has breaking stuff this year another
payoff pitch con smith turns it around
to deep center field way back
solo shot for will smith and the dodgers
strike first
will smith has not struggled with the
high fastball this year he has struggled
a little bit more with the low pitch as
the ball gets elevated he gets better
and you can tell by that swing he stayed
in the box and he goes i got that one
and that is the game for pierce johnson
pitching change from san diego
to right and myers off the bat of taylor
and that's the first out of the inning
802
high drive deep center tatis going back
he'll make the catch on the edge of the
dirt of the track
for out number two seeger back to first
two down you're at first with two down
padres in a shift
fly ball left field
fam is there waiting and he makes the
catch it puts an end to the second
inning
goes one two three in the first on just
eight pitches and so the heart of the
order coming up here with jake cronin
worth to leave things off
wow look at that thing sweep in there to
ring up cronin work
flies this wall to deep right center
field bellinger and taylor coming
together bollinger's got it
got this one off the end of the bat easy
play in center field for cody ballinger
julio ruiz has retired the first six
steadies fails
game one is a bullpen game and we're on
to our third pitcher emilio pagan into
this game
so two is strike three to urease that's
the first out of the third inning one
down in the third for trey turner
strike three
back-to-back strikeouts for emilio pagan
two down two down here in the third for
max muncie
fly ball to left and tommy pham makes
his way in
four out number three myers at 259 with
15 home runs
change up hit gently to third for
tournament nice play one guy
jason padre is nothing here's the eight
hitter hot song kim
high fast ball rings him off two up two
down in the third azurius gets his third
k
fights it off back of the infield and
julio riddis is perfect once through the
order the dodgers in front one nothing
number two on the mound for emilio pagan
here's the 2-2 from pagan swung on and
mixed got him to chase the fastball away
at 96 miles an hour
emilio pagan has faced four batters and
struck out three of them
one out here in the top of the fourth
for will smith two and two to smith one
out nobody on the pitch is on the
outside corner strike three called
another k for pagan two outs base is
empty for seeger seeger first pitch
swing in the air to left field tommy
pham charging in near the line he gets
there and makes the two-handed catch
audrey's had their first base runner of
the game
and the tying run aboard for fernando
tatis jr with nobody out leah strikes
him out can't lay off the high fast ball
now machado who bounced it short in his
first at-bat
[Applause]
fly ball
deep left field pollock to the wall it
is caught aj took it away
pollock robs machado and the dodgers
stay in front the ball was in the first
row
and it's not fan interference so he's up
there battling with some fans to get
this one not only does he time the jump
does the fan back off right at the end
no aj fights for it through three sets
of hands and catches
it it's as bad on this one and it's a
little teardrop over to seeger that's
the ending is back to the mound for the
bottom of the fifth padres still looking
for their first hit against julio who
faces austin nola to lead off this fifth
inning
high fastball working again trey turner
says that he's got it and does one go
into the fifth
and there's a base hit the first of the
night for the padres
taylor over to play at hospital thinking
two
he'll get to
kim will reach it first
hosmer will take third
and we'll see adam frazier another
one-two
is line to center field no big deal for
cody bellinger that's that for the
padres in the fifth
second and third one out taylor
diving at third as machado knocks it
down
and a nice play by manny but he is hurt
it appears
as soon as manny got up okay off the
glove that saves two runs he extends
there a little bit looks like he kind of
cradles that left arm a little bit
and machado is coming out of this game
it's to the top of the seventh inning
dodgers have him loaded with one out the
new pitcher is daniel hudson who takes
over for camarena it looks like machado
is going to be coming back out onto the
field
shoots it base hit into right field
one run is in here comes another throw
goes the third not in time and a two run
single for aj powell
rogers at first and third justin turner
coming out
2-2 again
wide to center field
four tattoos that's pretty deep enough
to bring home trey turner
give it in by justin turner and it's
four nothing
up four nothing they've got him in
second and third with one gone and
seeger
gets it off the end of the bat to center
field tati sizes it out makes the catch
muncie coming home the throws cut off
and now smith is out at third a timing
play but muncie stepped on home first a
five-nothing lead is walk the lead off
hitter and the bottom of the eighth and
that brings up jerks and profile
and a drive to right down the line
towards the pecco porch and that ball is
gone
jericho profile with a two-run shot here
come the padres
foresee where enable tries to go in but
look at him get the hands through
jerkster pro fighter says get out of my
kitchen he's sitting in the rocky chair
on the porch he went to the porch
two on for the padres and the tying run
will check in and it's jake cronenworth
2-2 he did and it struck him
ladder high with a counter to get
cronenworth all-star second baseman has
runners at first and second represents
the tying run
facing one of the hardest guys in the
league to strike out but ahead of him
owen two here he comes and he gets him
on three pitches to end the game
the dodgers beat the padres 5-2 and
they've won 14 out of 16.